ce fromage et travaille essentiellement
en circuit court pour son élevage sa
production et la vente sur des marchés
du coin
en juin il a obtenu l'agrément valeur
parc une marque commune à tous les parcs
régionaux de france
pour lui c'est une reconnaissance de son
mode de travail
je pense que sur les marchés ça sera un
support de communication et c'est sûr de
par le fait que c'est une marque qui est
national et je pense que que les
consommateurs vont rapidement
reconnaître cette marque sur les marchés
la marque est aussi affiché par les
hébergeurs les propriétaires de ce gîte
ont tout de suite adhéré au concept en
ils ont fabriqué ces bâtiments presque
autonome en énergie leur démarche répond
tout à fait aux cahiers des charges du
parc
ce nouvel agrément est un nouvel outil
de communication
ça nous amène de la clientèle et puis
nous ça nous amène une crédibilité déjà
sur le projet si on a eu la valeur c'est
qu'on répond aux critères du parc donc
ça veut dire que le projet était
crédible et derrière quand on oriente
aussi les clients sur la valeur parc ils
savent qu'ils s'attendent à des choses
de qualité qui respecte le parc naturel
régional du haut jura mettait déjà en
avant les hébergeurs les producteurs et
les artisans de son territoire
il les accompagne notamment en matière
de respect de l'environnement et des
paysages pour la structure l'agrément
est un support de communication mais pas
seulement
au-delà de ça en fait c'est vraiment de
pouvoir mettre en place des actions des
actions de mise en réseau entre les
acteurs de pouvoir aussi initié certains
projets par exemple le fait de pouvoir
approvisionner en produits locaux des
restaurants ou des gîtes et puis après
l'idée c'est vraiment que ce soit les
personnes qui sont en réseau donc les
producteurs les hébergeurs qui fasse
vivre en fait le réseau et qui eux mêmes
soit force de propositions par rapport à
des actions qu'il souhaite mettre en
place reste à faire connaître la marque
le public pourra rencontrer tous les
acteurs ce dimanche lors d'un grand
pique nique à la joue